foreign
let's go to Michelle in Burlington Coat
Factory Vermont what's up Michelle
good how are you good how are you
I'm doing good I'm here
um that's outstanding so what's up
yeah okay so I'm on baby step number two
and I have 3 222 of debt left oh you are
so close
total clothes but um before I started
this journey I agreed to go on a
two-week two-part kind of vacation and
then I also started a new job so I won't
have PT uh PTO
so I started up with my debt journey to
stop paying off the debt and I have 5
362 in my savings but every time I look
at that ratio it just kind of kills me
that I can't pay it off am I doing the
right thing
okay so you have you agreed to go on a
vacation who'd you agree to go on this
vacation with
the first week it's a family trip to
Florida and then the second week it's my
friend's bachelorette party which I'm in
the wedding okay and combined those
vacations are going to cost you about
five grand
because I also wanted to
um think about like monthly expenses for
the two weeks of work I'll be missing
and not getting paid for out okay so all
that combined is five thousand bucks
I'm hoping to get another I'm hoping to
get it to six
thousand just to be on the safe side
okay
so a couple of things here number one
you you agreed to this vacation of
family you agreed to be in this in your
friend's wedding and then they laid all
these expenses out and then you got a
new job
yeah okay so
as far as I'm concerned you got a new
job and that that is life outside of
vacation so if my if I had a friend that
was going to be in my wedding and he
called and said dude I lost my other job
I got laid off I took a new job I got no
paid time off
um I'm not going to be able to come on
the week-long blowout we were gonna do
I'd be like oh it's a bummer dude and he
would say I know man but I'll be there
for the wedding I'll be there for the
rehearsal dinner and all that and I
would be completely fine with that
and if I had a family event planned and
my little brother called and said hey I
got a new job I'm not going to be able
to make it we got started I would say
dude congratulations on getting a new
job so that's just me so as far as I'm
concerned I don't have any problem with
you reaching out to your family as an
Integrity interesting I got a new job I
don't have time off and I'm not in a
position right now to not get paid
the other side of that is
um every single one of my jobs including
the one I have now
I I live my life with SP I've been
speaking at places for years and so I've
got things on the calendar four months
six months sometimes nine months in
advance every single job I've had I've
come in saying hey I've already got
these things on the calendar is that
okay
and every single job I've taken they
have been like absolutely no problem
come on in
so I don't know if you've done that
already with your supervisor or sit down
and say hey I already had these on the
calendar when I took this and I should
have brought this up and I didn't but if
you think that would be a safe
conversation to have I would try that
too that way you're not losing that
money also
because I do know I have these vacations
planned and they're giving me the time
off but since I'm an hourly employee oh
they're just not paying you for it okay
yeah they're giving you permission to
choose to not get paid for two weeks
they're very nice
okay
how lovely so what is what's the hourly
pay
uh about 25 an hour okay and when are
these trips happening
uh
first week of November
all of it it's back to back yeah yeah as
far as basically fly out of Florida to
Arizona and you've already bought the
flights
yeah okay is that part of this 5000 that
you said
how much this is already paid for
yep
okay oh um the the hotels and the
flights you've already paid for those
yes but you're still thinking you're
gonna need all that money yeah what are
you spending what are you gonna do
um
I don't know if I have nieces and
nephews so I know I'm going to want to
like
We're Not Gonna spoil them when we're
broke no you don't you're broke honey
your time is what they want you don't
have the money
they want you to jump around in a pool
and throw them around someone else can
buy them ice cream yes
okay
so if I'm in if I'm in your shoes and
all this is paid for I'm gonna be debt
free today today
and I'm gonna figure out how to go spend
time with my family without trying to
buy their affection and if you don't
have the money you just tell them sorry
guys can't go out to eat tonight you'll
have fun and if they go hey we'll cover
your meal it's no big deal we go that's
so nice and you accept the generosity
and that's it and you take a flashlight
and you take the kids out and you all go
catch sand crabs and it will be the
adventure of a lifetime and they won't
remember the whirly gig you bought them
for fourteen dollars but they will
remember the time you got pinched on the
finger and you yelled the bad word and
you ran around like they'll remember
those things figure that out
is that cool
yes you are broke and you're about to be
debt free Tada what are you doing in
Arizona what do you have to pay for
um
I going out to dinner
um I think whenever we go out okay
and then there's like a wine tour
um
so bad stuff
I would be as conservative as you
possibly can be on that and I would be
really open because these are your ride
or dies these are your friends you're
close to them you all love each other
that you all are in each other's
weddings I would let them know I am
tired of being broke and I am getting
myself out of debt and so I'm gonna come
on the trip I'm gonna have dinner I'm
not pitching on the Ave on the appetizer
this time I'm drinking water I'm gonna
be that I'm gonna blame I know lame I
know I know I'll go to the wine tasting
I've already put in 300 bucks for that
I'm gonna go to that that's fine
um
but we're not I I'm gonna be smart about
this I'm not going to use this is it
time to just go off the rails here's why
you're broke
you can't afford it and I know like I
know I want to I know I I want it for
you but you're broke
and future Michelle is going to love
present Michelle exactly right going oh
my gosh I just got back from the trip
and I'm debt free yes and I've got a new
job and now I can focus on building the
emergency fund and living my life and
starting to invest and do all these
things and you're not having to carry
this debt around for who knows how much
longer because we blew it all the nieces
nephews and Wine Tours think of future
Michelle
think of President Michelle and future
Michelle ah here's a magic line choose
guilt over resentment every time
choose the guilt you feel over not
buying a bunch of stuff
a bunch of junk for kids they're gonna
it's gonna be gone it's gonna be thrown
away in the next two or three months
anyway
choose the guilt over the resentment of
I don't want to hang out with them
because I'm broke
choose the guilt over telling your
friends hey I'm not pitching in on this
super Atomic
I'm not I'm not doing the pedal Tavern
in downtown that's just a wise decision
always always I'm not doing it I don't
want to be on a pedal Tavern I'm not
doing it
um
choose guilt over the resentment you're
gonna feel when you're sweating drinking
whatever three yard beers you've got and
you're all annoyed that you didn't want
to do this in the first place you're
going to present to everybody choose
guilt over resentment choose it every
time should tweet that that's good well
I didn't come up with it so oh never
mind